Just keep your eyes peeled
for any signs of where
the railroad would have been.
NARRATOR: Now, the
train Bunch hit was
no run-of-the-mill locomotive.
This was one of them
high dollar jobs,
carrying folks in the high tax
bracket out of New Orleans.
But that old train
stopped running years ago.
So finding them tracks is going
to take more than a little
doing.
Judging by this
big hill right here,
I think this might have been
right where it passed at.
Brendan, I don't see any
pieces of the railroad, though.
Keep your eyes peeled to see
if we can find a piece of it.
BRENDAN: I'm keeping
them peeled, buddy.
We're going to try to
find the railroad tracks.
And we're going to follow
the tracks to where
he perpetrated the robbery.
What's this here?
Put some muscle to it.
[grunts]
Is that a piece of the track?
It sure is.
Yeah, that's all whole
piece of the track.
Pure evidence.
We're in the right location.
- Yeah.
All right.
Let's move out and see if
we can find anything else.
Let's go.
NARRATOR: This track led Bunch
to his biggest haul ever.
And the boys are hoping
it does the same for them.
I don't know what type
of clues we'll find.
But when we follow the
tracks, we'll be following
the footsteps of Eugene.
BRENDAN: Follow
the train tracks.
All right.
And maybe we'll find a clue
that no one's ever found before.
We're on the right track.
And I mean train track.
Look, it clears up here.
Clearly, this is where
the train tracks ran.
Right?
Eugene went from
being a schoolteacher
to a train robber, because
he caught the fever.
You know, if he was running
with a bunch of loot,
something could have
just popped out--
a coin, or, you
know, some jewelry.
The same fever that everyone
that's a treasure hunter
catches.
But it wasn't about the money.
It was about the
adventure and the thrill.
And that's why he
could never stop.
[beeping]
That's a good hit.
I have a great signal.
It's repetitive.
Same number, same
sound, over and over.
All right, let's pull it up.
Try and pop this out.
There you go, buddy.
Oh, look.
There it is, there it is.
What is it?
No way.
Told you we'd find gold.